uh this leadership debate what impact is
it having on the working of the house
i mean it's complete chaos just
yesterday um we have an ambulance crisis
that's hitting people across the country
and causing health workers and patients
untold anxiety and pain and yet the new
health secretary steve barclay just
seemingly couldn't be bothered to turn
up for an urgent question which labor's
shadow health secretary where streeting
had put on that crisis so he couldn't be
bothered to turn up yesterday we also
had the home secretary and you know
we're in the midst of a passport crisis
any number of other things going wrong
in her office and she didn't bother to
turn up to be scrutinized by the home
affairs select committee neither of
those two people are leadership
contestants and yet where were they
absent it's an absolute chaotic
government at the moment and really
britain does deserve better well i'll
put that to there's coffee whether it
was a zombie government and she said
quite often you wouldn't necessarily
have the health secretary there it would
be the health minister i i wasn't aware
of
the situation uh with pretty patel or
i'd have put that to her as well and she
also pointed out that there had been um
a cobra meeting so you know they are
taking it seriously
so where was he we need to hear what was
said in that cobra meeting and that
should have been the job of the health
secretary and i'm sorry just saying well
sometimes junior ministers do come on
yes that's true but this is a serious
national crisis and this is the tory
government that's completely chaotic
they're all over the place we've got
leadership contestants making unfunded
tax cuts promises all over the place
without really thinking about what
that's going to mean in terms of public
services and meanwhile we've got
government ministers who just seem to
can't be bothered to turn out to
parliament
um vote of no confidence in themselves
on monday that's rather taking the sting
out of what you were trying to do it's
extraordinary it is
unprecedented for any government of any
color to refuse to take a vote of no
confidence tabled by her majesty's
official opposition we did one that was
very very similar to the one the tories
put themselves on the 2nd of august 1965
where ted heath said criticized the then
labour leaders style of government and
the way he was handling the actually
cost of living crisis funnily enough and
where are we now a tory government who
only last week ministers were resigning
from every 20 minutes saying they had no
confidence in the prime minister
themselves but they're too scared or too
chaotic i don't know what it is to take
our emotion instead of which we've got
this very odd thing where the government
has tabled a motion of confidence in
itself obviously that's that's that's
something we will be voting against we
don't have confidence in them but i also
ask every tory mp
who last week said they didn't have
confidence in boris johnson to remember
that boris johnson is still in charge of
the government he's got a whole summer
of chaos that he could cause and if they
really meant what they said last week
every single tory mp needs to think long
and hard before they vote to say they
have confidence in a government which
continues to be led by boris johnson
well you talk about wasting
parliamentary time what's the point of
having this sort of vote which you
originally wanted when you know that you
don't have the numbers
well we want it because enough tory mps
has said they don't have confidence in
this prime minister but let's just take
a couple of examples of his pattern of
behavior we know
because he said so he confirmed it to
the liaison committee a parliamentary
committee last week just sort of hours
before he said that he will step down at
some point that this is someone who just
recklessly when foreign secretary went
and spent it stayed the night at the
home of a former kgb agent without his
security detail without his officials
pres present who knows what was said or
done at that meeting so that's one one
example of how likely this man treats
foreign security and national security
yes alexander lebedev who mysteriously
then pops up in the house of lords a
little while later now that's the man
it's not taking
yes his son sorry it's not a man who's
taking national security seriously so
that's a serious risk okay so that's one
thing he does the other thing is we know
that he does he is guilty of not telling
the truth because the police have found
him guilty of partying in 10 downing
street while everyone else was locked
down in the very first lockdown in 2020.
that's really not on so we got someone
who the government themselves said they
had no faith in like just last week mps
themselves 141 or so of them voted
against him in their vote of no
confidence recently and yet there he
varies over the course of the summer
when there will be no parliament to hold
him even to any account whatsoever yeah
but you're telling my viewers everything
that they know already so what's the
point of having a vote of no confidence
we already know and it's one that you're
gonna because he's still there
because he's still there because he's
still there and he shouldn't still be
there and the tories have got the chance
to do the honorable thing on monday and
i urge them all because otherwise they
are all culpable christmas ceremonies
they're all culpable they're voting for
to lose their own jobs potentially they
are voting to say what they already said
that they have no confidence in this
government led by boris johnson they
could do that now there are other people
who could run the country as a caretaker
prime minister i mean the tory party has
a deputy prime minister who isn't in the
running for the leadership there's other
people who are no longer in the
leadership contest who've got experience
i would rather we had a labor government
with the labour prime minister obviously
now what will happen on monday is that
tory mps if they vote to keep this prime
minister imposed over the summer they
are voting against their own consciences
many of them they're voting against the
national interest they are voting
against um having someone who might just
might take seriously national security
and being honest and truthful with the
british people i mean really the british
people do deserve better well the
british people who are struggling most
are getting 37 billion quid from this
government starting today
they are the same british people who
over the last two years have had to
suffer
15 1-5 tory tax rises so working people
aren't fooled by this take away with one
hand and then give back a bit with the
other hand they're not fooled they know
for instance that it's just not fair
that the super-rich can benefit from
things like non-dom tax status which is
where people can sort of claim residents
in different countries and therefore
avoid paying their fair share of tax
they know that it's not fair that small
businesses are having to pay rates that
are just business rates that just not
comparable with the way that big tech
companies and online companies can get
away with paying much less than their
fair share they know that's not fair and
they know that we need a fair tax system
that's why in my view we need a labor
government with kierstama in number 10
and the contrast with this current
government and this current
bunch of ministers and tory leadership
contestants spraying out unfunded tax
promises tax cut promises is quite
extraordinary contrast british people
deserve better um you know my viewers
are not deaf they know what non-dom
status means and they know that the
conservative party represent that and
they still voted for them uh well that
was two and a half years ago and they've
had to solve them
and during the last two years there have
been 15 tory tax rises on working people
on working people but most of those tax
risers have actually had most of those
tax tax rises but they're hitting
working people and that's the difference
isn't it okay you know we you can make a
decision in politics are you going to
hit working people the hardest or are
you going to actually close some of
those tax loopholes that benefit the
super-rich are you going to do things
that you actually promised to do this
government said it was going to cut vat
on fuel bills which it said was one of
the brexit benefits where's that promise
gone that would benefit working people
right now and you know what your viewers
as you said they're smart people they
will also be adding up can they afford
to pay their fuel bills at the end of
this month how are they going to get to
the end of the year that's something any
of the tory leadership contenders can
promise right now instead of which
they're promising unfunded tax cuts and
your viewers also know that that's not
on because it's their money that's
paying for those tax cuts with no
thought from those leadership contenders
of what that actually means for public
services that we all rely on yeah but we
also need to increase our defense
spending don't we because of what's
happening we do in europe and so that's
cost money as well yes where is this
magic money tree well it's called
growing the economy which under the last
12 years of tory government
unfortunately we've got stagnant growth
and if you want to but if you want to
bring in money for public services you
need to have economic growth which is
why kirsten has said it will be a top
priority for a labor government but it
also needs a fair tax system so that
when you bring in money for public
services you're not landing all of the
cost on working people and i've i've
said you know that the non-dom tax
status is not fair and it is it isn't
placing responsibility where it needs to
be and we need a fair tax system at the
moment what we think someone would
increase taxes for um higher earners
well i've just said we would abolish the
non-dom tax status yes but we would also
abolish the vat exemption for private
schools which would bring in 1.7 billion
pounds that we could be spending on
children's recovery in state schools and
i think again most people would agree
that's a fair tax system that's what we
need well i mean at the moment we don't
yet know the full extent of the chaos
that will be left to us when we come
into government so you wouldn't expect
me right as labour why do you always
back off when we talk about income tax
specifics you're very specific about
other taxes but you realize that income
tax increases is not what people will
vote for so you're always very cautious
well at the moment we have to it would
be irresponsible of me to say to your
viewers something they know we can't
fulfill so i can't do that without
making sure that we make a promise that
we can keep and that's why i think it's
important that we show people that when
we make a promise we know how we're
going to cut to afford it we know where
the money's coming from and as we don't
know unfortunately what chaos this
government will cause over the next
however long it's going to be i mean
whether it's going to be october or it's
going to be next may or the general
election we have to wait for for another
two years i think i would bet on that
one would you two years
which is one of the reasons why it'd be
irresponsible of me to bake a commitment
right now about income tax when we just
don't know what's going to be going on
who are you most afraid of i'm not
afraid of any of them as competition for
the labour party i think we are capable
we are a government in waiting i am
afraid of the damage they're going to do
to the country over the next two years
okay i'm not going to let you have
coffee before you come on in future
there's no stopping you this morning is
there i wouldn't want to be on the wrong
side of you this morning it's good to
see you thank you thanks a lot